[Music]
I've been a CTO I've been a VP but I
never had the business background in a
formal manner so I thought the lead
program for me was an opportunity to
kind of fill in the gaps and pick up
some of the business knowledge that I
never really had formal exposure to the
lead program it allowed me to get an
education that was similar to an MBA but
still allowed me to keep my full-time
job and my responsibilities and get the
kind of education that I wanted lead
provides you the opportunity to learn
and apply in a very very rapid iterative
fashion so you learn in the evening you
apply in the morning and none of the
other programs that are out there can be
that good having finished the lead
program when I talk to people at work
and I use different concepts and I can
apply it straightaway to any innovation
that we want to do or influencing so
really applicable it's a complete mind
shaping experience yeah I mean I'm
friends we would say office not
therefore myself yeah and this is
different when I researched online there
wasn't a program which even come closer
to this program the interaction and the
guiding that you get access to the
different lecturers and actually
interacting with them and the groups
that you build up and the networks that
you get is completely different to any
of the online courses that I've done we
are living in the world which is really
changing which is very dynamic and I
think this program give you the skills
you can apply in the modern world
and be ready to face different
challenges it's a very very fast-paced
program but it will give you tools that
are applicable immediately and it'll
give you tools that I never got even
from my MBA so if you're interested in
taking your firm and taking your
knowledge level to the next stage
innovating disrupting this is the place
go for it absolutely absolutely go for
it you get access to all these amazing
people your peers as well as the
lecturers try and get everything out of
it that you can it's going to cost you a
lot of time so be prepared for a year to
actually spend that time and you have to
really take that into account because
otherwise you just don't get everything
out of it I was a little apprehensive
going into it like that I want to commit
as much time and do I can I commit this
much study time it's been a long time
stepping in school for me it was very
fulfilling in that regard because we
kind of
give me the feeling that I you know it's
it's lifelong learning at the end of the
day it's a journey and when you come out
the other side for me I feel pretty
changed I really feel like the
experience has given me a lot of
knowledge and
the experience that I hadn't had before
you